[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara Hellweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den
sporthemen von heute
historische waffenpartnerschaft
Deutschland erhält von Israel das
hochmoderne Raketenabwehrsystem Arrow 3
die USA gaben dafür jetzt grünes Licht
die Dunkelziffer bei Ärztepfusch ist
hoch Krankenkassen und patientenschützer
fördern mehr Rechte für Betroffene vor
allem mehr Transparenz
und Wetterchaos in Deutschland starke
Gewitter richten große Schäden an und es
folgt eine weitere Hitzewelle am
Wochenende
[Musik]
seit dem russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine ist klar europa muss sich
schützen dafür hat Deutschland in Israel
ein Raketenabwehrsystem bestellt das
Israel zusammen mit den USA entwickelt
hat Washington hat heute der Lieferung
zugestimmt israelische Politiker
sprechen von einem historischen Tag
Arrow 3 ist eines der leistungsfähigsten
Raketenabwehrsysteme es kann Ziele in
bis zu 100 Kilometer Höhe zerstören fast
vier Milliarden Euro soll es kosten für
Israel der größte rüstungsstil der
Geschichte für Deutschland eine
besondere Verantwortung Arrow 3 soll
Teil eines europäischen
luftverteidigungssystems werden aus
berlin-mattes Feldhoff
Abschluss einer ro3 abfangrakete dieses
Luftverteidigungssystem soll demnächst
auch Deutschland schützen für knapp 4
Milliarden Euro kauft die Bundeswehr
jetzt das System es ist natürlich viel
Geld aber es geht um die Sicherheit der
Bundesrepublik und es geht auch um die
Anrainerstaaten letztlich verbirgt sich
dahinter der europäische Schild das aus
der Luft wir sind völlig blank wenn ein
Angriff aus der Luft kommt R3 schließt
eine Lücke im deutschen Verteidigung
Schild mit einer Reichweite von 2400 km
soll es Interkontinentalraketen bereits
im Anflug bekämpfen herausragend dabei
die hohe Präzision
das neue System ergänzt die vorhandenen
Abwehrsysteme der Bundeswehr das 40
Jahre alte patriotsystem das derzeit
unter anderem in der Ukraine eingesetzt
wird und das neue ihres c-system das
zwar schon bestellt aber noch nicht
geliefert wurde error 3 kommt
vergleichsweise schnell schon im Jahr
2025 es wird in Brandenburg stationiert
werden und dann werden wir noch ein
zweites und ein drittes System kaufen
wobei ein System in Norddeutschland
abgesetzt wird und ein System in
Süddeutschland und wir können dann mit
diesen drei Systemen das gesamte Gebiet
Deutschlands abdecken für Israel ist das
Geschäft mit Deutschland der größte
Rüstungsexport seiner Geschichte
entsprechend euphorisch klingt der
Verteidigungsminister dieses System wird
mit unserer Hilfe Deutschland einen
Schutzschirm geben wir sind sehr stolz
dass die Deutschen sich für unser System
entschieden haben
ob die fast 4 Milliarden Euro gut
angelegt sind ist umstritten manche
Kritiker sagen die Bedrohung durch
Langstrecken Raketen existiere gar nicht
für Europa aber Europa lernt gerade wie
schnell sich eine Bedrohungslage ändern
kann
fragen wir Isabel Schäfers in Brüssel
welche Rolle spielt Arrow 3 für die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit Europas ja also
das Vorhaben muss man sehen als Teil
einer größeren Initiative um die gesamte
europäische Luftverteidigung zu
verbessern dafür wurde im vergangenen
Jahr die sogenannte Europeans Sky Shield
Initiative angestoßen von Deutschland
weil durch den russischen Angriffskrieg
eben plötzlich die Defizite in der
europäischen Luftverteidigung so
deutlich wurden die Hauptidee ist
eigentlich das gemeinsame koordiniert
besser angeschafft werden kann und eben
am günstigsten und effizientesten die
Luftverteidigung ausgebaut werden kann
deswegen wird jetzt eben diese Systeme
gemeinsam beschafft und gewartet und
auch genutzt mittlerweile sind 19
europäische Länder teil dieser
Initiative fast alles NATO Mitglieder
und auch die NATO selbst unterstützt die
Initiative weil dadurch eben die
nato-verteidigung insgesamt gestärkt
werden kann so heißt es hier Arrow 3
kann nicht alle Lücken in der
europäischen
Luftverteidigung schließen aber es wäre
eben ein nächster Schritt danke schön
für diese Einschätzung aus Brüssel
Isabel Schäfers
die Ukraine werde von westlichen
Verbündeten gelieferte Waffen nicht auf
russischen Gebiet einsetzen das
versicherte jetzt noch mal der
ukrainische Außenminister Kollege seit
Wochen bittet Deutschland um
Marschflugkörper vom Typ Taurus genau
wie bei den Leopard Panzern müssten
dafür ukrainische Soldaten ausgebildet
werden von so einem panzertraining bei
der Bundeswehr berichtet Henriette de
Maiziere
Truppenübungsplatz in Sachsen-Anhalt
hier werden ukrainische Soldatinnen und
Soldaten an Panzern des Typs Leopard 1
A5 ausgebildet die Ausbildung findet im
Rahmen der EU-Mission zur militärischen
Unterstützung der Ukraine statt für
Männer und Frauen die manchmal gerade
erst die Grundausbildung durchlaufen
haben wenn sich dann vor Augen führen
was diese
kameradenkameraden die nicht
professionelle Soldaten sind oder nur
ganz wenige von denen hierher kommen und
dann von 0 auf diesen Stand gebracht
werden innerhalb weniger Wochen das
finde ich immer wieder beeindruckend die
Geheimhaltungsstufe hoch niemand soll zu
erkennen sein Jeff jenny ist 32 Jahre
alt kommt aus der Ostukraine in seinem
zivilen Leben arbeitet er als Elektriker
wie fühlt er sich wenn er jetzt bald in
den Krieg zurückgeht
wir sind gut gerüstet wir haben hier
eine gute Ausbildung bekommen nun sind
wir bereit die Erfahrung von hier werden
uns helfen
bis zu sechs Wochen dauert die
Ausbildung der ukrainischen Soldatinnen
und Soldaten hier am Stützpunkt
insgesamt sind deutschlandweit schon
6000 ausgebildet worden 10.000 sollen es
bis Ende des Jahres sein bei der Übung
heute wurden 15 von 17 Zielen getroffen
das sei eine sehr gute Quote
eine Einschätzung zur aktuellen Lage im
ukrainekrieg gibt der Militärexperte
Gustav gressel in ZDF heute live um
19:30 Uhr in der ZDF heute App und auf
unseren Social Media Kanälen
nach Spanien die Parlamentswahl vor
einem Monat endete mit einem Pat jetzt
ist den Sozialisten von
Ministerpräsident Sanchez ein Etappen
Sieg gelungen bei der konstituierenden
Sitzung Welten die Abgeordneten die
Sozialistin franzine Armin Gold zur
Parlamentspräsidentin dabei erhielt sie
auch die Stimmen katalanischer
Separatisten um weiter zu regieren ist
Sanchez auf deren Unterstützung
angewiesen stärkste Kraft ist die
konservative PP die auch gemeinsam mit
der rechtspopulistischen Fox keine
Mehrheit hat
fehlerhafte Operationen beschädigte
Implantate verwechselte Medikamente
Behandlungsfehler in deutschen Kliniken
und Arztpraxen passieren immer wieder
werden bislang aber nicht zentral
erfasst der medizinische Dienst fordert
deshalb eine Meldepflicht für besonders
schwere Fälle
allein die Gutachter der Krankenkassen
registrierten im vergangenen Jahr
2696 Behandlungsfehler die nachweislich
zu gesundheitlichen Schäden führten die
Dunkelziffer dürfte deutlich höher
liegen Stefanie Hein
ihr Leben gerät vor knapp sieben Jahren
völlig aus den Fugen Yalda die Tänzer
damals überglücklich schwanger in der 35
Woche dann geht es ihr schlecht heftige
Bauchschmerzen das Krankenhaus ihre
Heimatstadt verlegt sie in eine
Uniklinik der Verdacht sagt sie
help-syndrom eine
Schwangerschaftskomplikation
lebensgefährlich für Mutter und Kind
keiner wollte mir glauben dass es hier
um wirklich unsagbare Schmerzen geht und
das die Situation sich schlagartig
verschlechtert also ich wurde quasi
zu behandelt als wäre ich gar nicht
schwanger also mein wenn ich nur ich
wurde ignoriert sondern auch mein Kind
ein schneller Kaiserschnitt unterbleibt
hier die ihre ungeborene Tochter stirbt
Yalda Monster die Tänzer wird in der
Folge zigmal operiert Organ Versagen
innere Blutungen sie liegt zwei Wochen
im Koma ein Verschulden der ganzen
klinikorganisation sagt ja Anwalt
einfach schlichtweg nicht genug Ärzte
und Pfleger da und wenn der Notfälle
eintreten dann können Ärzte nicht an
zwei Orten sein und dann passieren
solche Sachen aber sowas darf natürlich
in einer Klinik der Maximalversorgung
nicht passieren zu mal hier wirklich
auch grob fehlerhaft gehandelt wurde der
medizinische Dienst stellt immer wieder
schwerwiegende Behandlungsfehler fest
die vermeidbar wären sie fordern hier
dafür eine Meldepflicht für den besseren
Überblick welche Fehler und Risiken
waren in den ab Läufen dass so ein
Fehler passiert ist und dass man nicht
mehr schaut wie man früher oft getan hat
wer war schuld und meint dann sei das
Problem erledigt
Yalda Monster die Tänzer will sich
niemals mehr so hilflos fühlen und ist
stolz dass sie den Gerichtsprozess
durchsteht der jetzt sieben Jahre später
hoffentlich zu Ende geht
in Niedersachsen Bremen und
Sachsen-Anhalt ist heute erster Schultag
nach den Sommerferien gewesen und das
neue Schuljahr beginnt mit altbekannten
Problemen chronische Lehrermangel gehört
fast überall in Deutschland dazu wie
Bremen damit umgeht zeigt keine Flasche
Mutter wird wer eine hat kann sich
freuen denn Lehrerin und Lehrer sind
auch zum diesjährigen Schulbeginn in
ganz Deutschland knapp die Folge Ausfall
von Unterrichtsstunden wir hatten
Spanisch ist sehr lange ausgefallen ein
halbes Jahr aber jetzt ist es wieder es
ist halt dass ich manchmal Angst habe
dass ich die Abschlussprüfung nicht
schaffe weil die wird ja nicht extra für
unsere Klasse bzw die Schule
umgeschrieben um die Situation
kurzfristig zu entschärfen schrieb etwa
die Bremer Bildungssenatorin Sascha olep
einen Brandbrief in dem sie
teilzeitjobberbad aufzustocken oder
früher aus der Elternzeit zurückzukehren
wir haben immens steigende Zahlen an
Schülerinnen und Schülern die wir alle
gut beschulen wollen deswegen haben wir
viele Maßnahmen ergriffen etwa
Quereinsteiger wie Felix Göbel zu
gewinnen der Geografie studiert hat und
lange als Stadtplaner arbeitete er wird
ab diesen Schuljahr unterrichten
entschieden habe ich mich dafür weil es
die Möglichkeit gab also weil das
Angebot was gerade durch den
Quereinstieg möglich ist
sehr attraktiv für mich daher kam damit
sich andere ähnlich entscheiden fordern
die Gewerkschaften aber nachhaltige
Veränderungen und außerdem natürlich
haben wir im Moment auch keine
attraktiven Arbeitsplätze auch da sage
ich mal ist jahrelang dran gespart
worden und man hat nicht darauf gehört
dass die Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr
sehr belastet sind bis zum Jahr 2030
sagen Studien einen Mangel an 80.000
Lehrkräften in Deutschland voraus
dieser Sommer ist speziell kaum ein Tag
ohne wetterschlag sein gestern Abend
traf es vor allem das ruhegebiet und die
rhein-main-regierung Gewitter Starkregen
25.000 Blitze in einer Stunde und es war
gar nicht so einfach diesen deutschen
Sommer hinter sich zu lassen viele
Urlauber strandeten am Frankfurter
Flughafen
Bahnfahren war aber auch schwierig wieso
seiner Santina zeigt
im Südbahnhof Frankfurt gab es für die
Wassermassen kein Halten mehr schwere
Gewitter und extremer Starkregen hatten
in der Nacht für den Wassereinbruch und
die komplette Überflutung des Bahnhofs
gesorgt
in der Mainmetropole fiel in kurzer Zeit
so viele Regen wie normalerweise im
gesamten Monat August besonders
betroffen war auch der Frankfurter
Flughafen die Folge dutzende
Verspätungen und Flugausfälle und 2500
Passagiere mussten am Boden bleiben
auch wegen vollgelaufener Keller und
überfluteter Straßen war die Feuerwehr
vielerorts im Rhein-Main-Gebiet im
Dauereinsatz wie hier in Rüsselsheim kam
es zu zahlreichen Unfällen
Land unter auch in Essen hier traf es
unter anderem zahlreiche Wohnungen die
in einer Senkel lagen die Erdgeschosse
komplett unter Wasser und auch viele
Keller
was passiert ohne Strom ohne alles sind
das Wasser kam so schnell die Tür ist
rausgebrochen
eine Katastrophe auch für die Feuerwehr
die mit Verstärkung im Einsatz ist sind
die gewaltigen Wassermassen in so kurzer
Zeit eine große Herausforderung
tatsächlich ein Meter hoch aus dem Boden
rausgeschossen und haben fast unsere
Einsatzfahrzeuge getroffen und viele
Einsätze gehen auch heute noch weiter in
mehreren Bundesländern müssen sich die
Menschen erneut auf Unwetter einstellen
über dürren redet hierzulande gerade
kaum jemand und doch bleibt die
Trockenheit der letzten Jahre ein
Problem auch für die Wasserversorgung
die
Rappbodetalsperre in Sachsen-Anhalt ist
die größte Trinkwassertalsperre in
Deutschland sie versorgt etwa 1,3
Millionen Menschen bis Halle und Leipzig
warum das Waldsterben im Harz ein
Problem für die Wasserqualität ist zeigt
Lana Ullmann
die Rappbodetalsperre und ihre
gigantische 106 m hohe Staumauer
eingebettet im Harzer Forst drei Viertel
des Harzes war früher ein einziger
Dichter Fichtenwald seit fünf Jahren ist
dies Vergangenheit diese Weltkatastrophe
die uns hier betroffen hat hat 2018
eingesetzt mit enormen Sturmschäden und
diese Sturmschäden sind dann eskaliert
und diese gigantische Trockenheit die
wir über drei vier Jahre hatten 90% des
Fichtenwaldes ist tot wenn der Wald
stirbt wird unser Wasser schlechter eine
nahezu unaufhaltsame Kettenreaktion so
Klimaforscher Carsten Rinke all diese
Stoffe die eigentlich im Wald
zurückgehalten werden in den in der in
dem Lebensraum Wald die werden dann
natürlich zum Teil mobil und mit dem
Wasser auch in die Talsperre eingetragen
das möchte man nicht seit Jahren wird
ein erhöhter Gehalt an huminstoffen also
verrottetem Pflanzenmaterial und
Stickstoffen aus Düngemitteln gemessen
höre Aufwand mehr Kosten bei der
Trinkwasseraufbereitung im Wasserwerk
sind die Folge um agile auf die
kommenden Schadstoffe reagieren zu
können wurde ein
wasserüberwachungssystem entwickelt das
Trio umwelt-institut Wasserwirtschaft
und talsperrenbetrieb wird alle 15
Minuten mit Messdaten versorgt so können
Sie zusammen schnell konzentriert
handeln wir müssen uns jetzt anpassen
ich kann diesen Wald nicht mehr
zurückholen der ist weg ich muss jetzt
reagieren und versuchen das System so
umzubauen das ist mit der zukünftigen
Klimasituation besser klarkommen für den
Harz bedeutet das
klimaresistentere Bäume pflanzen und
einen Mischwald heran züchten das wird
Jahrzehnte dauern wird aber das Wasser
in der Zukunft sichern
der Mensch verändert die Erde
mittlerweile sind sich Forscher sicher
der menschliche Einfluss ist so
gravierend das ist ein neues
Erdzeitalter gibt kleiner Rückblick vor
2,4 Millionen Jahren begann mit der
Vergletscherung der Arktis das
Pleistozän umgangssprachlich Eiszeit vor
10.000 Jahren erwärmte sich unser Planet
Start des Holo 10s seit 1950 wachsen
Industrie und Konsum derart das Geologen
vom Anthropozän sprechen dem Zeitalter
des Menschen nachzuweisen zum Beispiel
an einem See in Kanada
er ist unscheinbar klein abgelegen und
doch finden sich auf dem Grund von
Crawford Lake die besten Argumente dass
ein neues Kapitel in der Erdgeschichte
begonnen hat Professor McCarthy und
Wissenschaftler aus aller Welt fordern
dass offiziell das Anthropozän
ausgerufen wird in dem erstmals Menschen
die Erdentwicklung massiv beeinflussen
wir bemerken ja alle die Veränderungen
in der Umwelt warum sollte das nicht in
der Erdgeschichte so vermerkt werden
als bester Maßstab für alles was der
Mensch der Natur angetan hat mit
Trockeneis und Ethanol füllten die
Forscher hier Stahlröhren versenken sie
im See die Sedimente die an den Röhren
festfroren belegen dramatische
Veränderungen seit Mitte des letzten
Jahrhunderts
Professor Petersen zeigt uns an den
Schichten wie damals wegen sauren Regens
die jährlichen kalzidablagerungen
verschwanden industrielle
Luftverschmutzung massiver Dünger
Einsatz atombombenfest alles hinterließ
Spuren
wegen all dieser Anhaltspunkte und allem
was mit der enormen bevölkerungsmenge
heute zu tun hat wird es nie wieder so
sein wie es vorher war
es ist etwas durcheinander geraten auf
der Erde anhaltende Extremwetter Lagen
der Golfstrom verlangsamt sich
Luftströmungen wie der Jetstream sehen
würde aus wie Gemälde von Van Gogh
die Prognosen der Wissenschaftler
klingen düster aber ihre Forschung
beweist gleichzeitig auch dass wir
Menschen die Entwicklung der Erde
verändern können also nicht nur zum
Schlechten sondern auch zum Guten und
dabei hilft die Einsicht vom Grund des
Crawford Lake zum neuen Kapitel der
Erdgeschichte dem anthropo
tja jetzt Sport heute mal nicht Fußball
der Frauen Norbert sondern Fußball der
Männer der UEFA Supercup war offenbar
super spannend allerdings 90 Minuten
plus 11 Meter schießen
Champions League Sieger Manchester City
gegen den Europa League Gewinner FC
Sevilla eine Begegnung auf Augenhöhe am
Ende aber hatten pep Guardiola und seine
Sky Blues das entscheidende Quäntchen
Glück
der nächste Titel in der Sammlung von
Manchester City ist perfekt nach dem
Champions League Kuh folgt der Gewinn im
europäischen Supercup
nur noch einer um den Kreis zu schließen
und für diesen Club alle Titel zu
gewinnen die möglich sind das wird im
Dezember folgen wenn wir nach Saudi
Arabien reisen die Club WM spielen
zunächst legt der Europa League Sieger
vor 25 Minute Yusuf elisiri vom FC
Sevilla mit dem 1:0 in der zweiten
Halbzeit gleich Man City in der 63 durch
das Tor von Cold Palmer aus
Unentschieden nach 90 Minuten ist folgt
direkt das Elfmeterschießen für
Manchester City trifft Kai Walker
Sevillas Modell zeigt Nerven und trifft
nur die Latte sieht ihr mit dem vierten
Titel im erfolgreichsten Jahr der
Vereinsgeschichte
die frühere deutsche Weltfußballerin
Nadine Kessler könnte neue DFB
Geschäftsführerin werden und damit die
Nachfolge von Oliver Bierhoff antreten
laut Medienberichten soll die 35-Jährige
die Bereiche dfb-akademie und
Nationalmannschaften übernehmen zu den
European para Championships da haben die
Deutschen rollstuhlbasketballerinnen ihr
Halbfinalspiel verloren sie unterlagen
gestern Abend den Rotterdam
Großbritannien deutlich mit 34 zu 750
und spielen nun um Bronze
versteinerte Minen und große
Enttäuschung nach dem Spiel nur im
ersten Viertel hat das deutsche Team den
Gegner im Griff hier Mareike Miller mit
einem sauberen Abschluss dann aber
lassen sich die Deutschen von den
aggressiven Britin in zwei Kämpfe
verwickeln und verlieren ihre
Treffsicherheit Grund zum Jubeln hat in
der zweiten Hälfte nur noch
Großbritannien denn die beste Frau auf
dem Platz Robin love sorgt allein für
die Hälfte der britischen Körper und
führt ihr Team ins Finale gegen die
Niederlande Deutschland hat morgen auf
Bronze gegen Spanien
ja soeben haben auch die deutschen
Basketball Männer auch ihr
Halbfinalspiel auch gegen Großbritannien
auch deutlich verloren schade schade für
Teile Bayerns wird vor Gewittern mit
Starkregen gewarnt die können auch
extrem heftig ausfallen und für den
Süden und Osten Deutschlands gibt es
hitzewarnungen mehr zum Wetter gleich
von herrlich eine begrüßt sie ihm heute
journal um kurz nach 10 wir wünschen
Ihnen noch einen entspannten Abend bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der nach den
schweren Unwettern gestern von gestern
Abend hat es sich etwas beruhigt auch
wenn es immer noch Gewitter gibt und die
sind durchaus noch vereinzelt im
unwetterbereich in den nächsten Stunden
aber bis morgen beruhigt sich das Ganze
es kommt immer noch warme teils heiße
Luft und hier in diesem tief steckt eine
kaltfronti erreicht uns dann am Samstag
in der Nacht also unten in den nächsten
Stunden noch schauen und Gewitter das
wird allmählich weniger das Ganze lässt
also nach Temperaturen sinken auf 14
Grad am Alpenrand und 19 Grad im
Rhein-Main-Gebiet das ist die
Temperaturspanne der nachts
morgen im Tagesverlauf einzelne Schauer
und Gewitter z.B in der Mitte das wird
er selten der Fall sein häufig scheint
eher die Sonne Temperaturen dazu mit
höchsten Temperaturen bis 35 Grad im
Südwesten generell ja also eine hohe
Hitzebelastung Werte um die 30 Grad
Marke 21 Grad in Schleswig-Holstein
nächsten Tage bleiben heißt und am
Samstag kommen im Nordwesten Schauer und
Gewitter auf bis 35 Grad Sonntag und
Montag deutlich Trockner ein schönen
Abend